okay so spider-man noway home seemingly
has a lot of plot holes in it that not
only break the multiverse but also the
rules of the film the first of those
being how venom was able to come across
to the mcu in the movie we are clearly
told that the cast of characters jump
over from their universes because they
know that peter parker is spider-man
when the spell was broken it brought
across a lot of villains into the
universe including the green goblin dr
octopus sandman the lizard and electro
who we'll talk about in just a bit
however it also brought across venom and
as he never actually interacted with
peter people are confused as to how he's
in the mcu now in order to understand
this we have to look at the end of venom
like debbie carnage namely what happened
in its post-credits scene as eddie brock
sat on his hotel bed venom said he'd
show him a fraction of the knowledge
that his hive mind had collected
throughout the entire cosmos in case you
don't know venom actually comes from a
race of symbiotes called the clinton
that all had a collected consciousness
at one point they used to worship a god
called null and in the comics he created
them as one branching mind that he
spread amongst the stars at the
beginning of loki episode 6 we actually
pulled out from our own solar system and
then flew into a universe nearby it in
order to see the branching path that
logi had gone on after the events of
avengers endgame whenever the multiverse
is depicted in the comics it's often
shown as having worlds beside each other
and it makes sense that this principle
would extend to the universe too thus if
we look at the way that the multiverse
operates in the mcu it is possible to
travel into another dimension by simply
traveling far enough so that you get to
the space beyond space now the reason
i'm telling you all this is because
venom talks about how his species have
collected information as far as 80
billion light years all at distance and
you would assume that this contains
things from other realities and
dimensions thus when venom and eddy
tapped into this they likely could have
gained some of the wisdom from the
symbiote that was in the raimiverse that
also knew peter parker was spider-man
potentially as venom and eddie tapped
into this info they also happened to be
doing it as the spell was being cast in
the sanctuarium and thus it is possible
that they were pulled across because of
this hopefully that answers your
question and i've just realized that i
haven't actually introduced myself yet
so if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and if you've
enjoyed the video so far we'd appreciate
the little thumbs up little little
thumbs up is all i want otherwise i'm
gonna go to a church and pray that god
kills you and also peter parker now the
spell at the end of no way home
completely erased the information from
everyone's mind that peter parker
existed i don't know what the big deal
with mj was as i've kissed plenty of
people that i don't remember but beyond
that peter has had a lot of connections
to the other characters in the mcu
including the avengers i think unless we
get an answer from marvel themselves
that there's gonna be a lot of back and
forth over whether peter is still in the
team or not but we can we can milk it a
bit in this video and discuss exactly
what we think now personally i don't
think that he's in the group and i
believe that though the avengers will
remember fighting alongside him they
won't remember that he's part of their
ranks as they'd have no idea who's
beneath the costume he clearly
introduced himself to captain marvel and
avengers endgame and after civil war
most of them knew he was just a kid so
they probably knew his real identity
because of this i think it's tied in
with his membership as well but i
actually don't think that he'll be in
the group for a meta reason after far
from home sony and marvel had to
renegotiate the contract around the
character i actually think that these
discussions very much played into the
ending of this movie noe home pretty
much culminates in a way that peter
parker can go off in his own and be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man and
because of this he won't be tied as
closely to the mcu i don't see why they
would have carried this out at the end
of the movie just to have him go back to
the group like nothing had happened in
order to get into the avengers he'd have
to reveal his identity and peter has
already seen the kinds of issues that
can crop up if people learn who he is
because of this i very much think that
spider-man will remain a vigilante
tackling low-level stuff and this will
actually work better for what we see
spider-man as the mcu definitely threw
him in at the deep end and though i've
enjoyed watching him going toe-to-toe
with thanos i do prefer the character
fighting more human level threats now we
will of course see and it's even
possible that by the time i released
this video that marvel will have come
out and called me a complete idiot so
yeah let the comments come in beyond
that though there are a lot of questions
on the spell and how the physical
evidence of peter parker's existence
would be handled when you think about it
there's a cabinet at his school that has
his face and spiderman side by side all
the news reports and of course the
flashpoint book that may or may not have
been marvel making fun of the flash
movie now these all exist and you could
easily look up that peter parker is
spider-man but the population is
actually hypnotized so that it doesn't
matter peter parker would still be
something that exists in those records
but people would either just not process
this information or it would be
something that they can't really
remember the details of if you've ever
been to a hypnotist stack before then
you'll have seen that people can't
remember simple details like their name
or how to counter temp properly i think
that the spell would very much work in
this way and that peter would be
something that they just can't seem to
remember if you've seen harry potter
then you'll know that a forgetting spell
was carried out in that and it basically
just means that people can somewhat
remember things but not to the point
that they have any recognition of the
details for example you probably watch
thousands of tv shows a year but if
someone was like remember what happened
in episode three of daredevil season one
you'd probably sort of be like i can't
do your accent i sort of remember that
med and foggy took on a mysterious
client and then talked to wesley but you
wouldn't remember the details of that
conversation unless of course you're
just in a 29 hour binge of all the
seasons just so you could talk about
kingpin in a hawkeye video which is
linked below now the details are there
in your head and you somewhat remember
them being there but you can't quite put
your finger on exactly what happened or
who peter is actually asked my granted
who peter parker was last night and he
said who's peter parker so it does seem
like the spell did indeed work now i
also view it as working in the same way
that the silent's doing doctor who these
aliens could be looked at and perceived
but as soon as you looked away you
completely forgot about them and
couldn't remember what had just happened
the same thing happens with sleeper
cells and i know i touched on the spell
in my last video but i thought i'd go
over it in a bit more detail as there's
still some confusion now as for how
electro knew well i think that's
probably the biggest plot hole in the
film we are told that people who know
peter parker is spider-man come across
when the spell breaks but later on
electro is surprised to learn that the
spider-man of his universe is white so
how could he come across if he didn't
actually know the webhead's true
identity well if you cast your mind back
to the end of the amazing spider-man 2
electro is actually absorbing all the
energy so that he could become one with
data this would allow him to tap into
everything on the planet similar to
cyborg from the dc universe he'd have
access to every piece of technology on
earth and also all the data on the
internet so i believe that when he did
this he learned the info but it was
locked away in his mind and he just
didn't tap into it electro sees the tom
holland version of the character early
on and come the fight he was probably
too preoccupied with that to really
delve into the identity of the one from
his universe thus this could be how he's
brought across or it could just be a
plot hole that i've used to put in a
video so that i can make money on
youtube is that is that it maybe but
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
below now as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of december in
which we're giving away three copies of
the spider-man 4k trilogies all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then messaging me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you have any other
burning questions then make sure you
check out our break and have some of the
other ones which will be linked on
screen right now we should have you
covered between these two videos so
hopefully i see over there right after
this without the way thank you for
sitting through the breakdown i've been
paul and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace